تجاوز الاتجاه الصعودي للنفط الخام على مدى عشر سنوات ،
حيث تراجعت أسعار النفط الأمريكي بنسبة تزيد
عن 20 في المائة من أعلى مستوى لها مؤخرًا ،
مما دفعهم إلى الدخول في سوق هابطة ، وهو
تحول مذهل قبل بضعة أشهر فقط ،
وتوقع بعض المحللين أن يرتفع سعر النفط
إلى 100 دولار للبرميل.  ما حدث بسبب
مجموعة من العوامل ، هناك مخاوف
من تباطؤ النمو العالمي الذي قد يعني
انخفاض الطلب على النفط مما يؤدي إلى انخفاض الأسعار
في نفس الوقت الذي يوجد فيه الكثير من
المعروض ، تغرق أمريكا السوق
بكمية قياسية من النفط الخام أكثر
من 40 عامًا في المملكة العربية السعودية و  تضخ دول أخرى في أوبك
المزيد من النفط - على الرغم من أن
تلك الدول تخطط لخفض
الإنتاج وأن العقوبات الأمريكية على إيران
ليست صارمة كما يخشى البعض من أن إدارة ترامب
منحت إعفاءات
مؤقتة للهند والصين وعدد قليل من الدول الأخرى التي
تسمح لهم بمواصلة شراء النفط من
إيران التي تجنبت على الأقل ضغطًا مؤقتًا في
الإمدادات ، لذا فإن النفط الآن موجود في Bear
Den والشركات التي تقوم بالتنقيب من
أجله تتعرض
للضرب بالطبع.  w كانت أسعار النفط مكسبًا
لبعض القطاعات المعتمدة على الوقود مثل
الخطوط الجوية وشركات المواد الكيميائية
التي يحتفل بها المستهلكون - بدأت أسعار الغاز في
الانخفاض أخيرًا بعد رفضها
التزحزح عن أعلى مستوى لها في أربع سنوات تقريبًا في
معظم عام 2018
[موسيقى]